okay the new york city marathon is just
two days away and we've all been
prepping all week long by carb loading
with some of our very favorite chefs and
today we are joined by an award-winning
chef an incredible restaurant tour and
an author who just released her latest
cookbook
pasta
ladies and gentlemen one of my favorite
chefs on planet earth i can't believe
she's here
it's missy robin
so happy to be here thank you
this cookbook hurts my soul
it is drop the mic unbelievably graphic
and beautiful
thank you
okay well i am so excited to be doing
this marathon week with you now today we
are joined by a first-time marathon
runner please say hello to maddie nguyen
[Applause]
what inspired to take the plunge
to do my first marathon yes i'm running
for an incredible organization called
camp kesem which aims to serve children
whose parents have been affected by
cancer so i'm really really excited for
sunday
we will be cheering
okay missy oh my gosh i've been waiting
to be your little student and sous chef
okay okay today we are making a dish
called corzetti el erbe
which is basically corzetti with herbs
and corzetti is this incredible pasta um
these little discs uh with which come
from the region of ligoria in
in italy so we have we have some pasta
sheets here
um that have been rolled out nice and
thin i have a pasta and this is
an incredible thing called a corzetti
stamp
um so you use this side to cut a little
round out and really kind of press hard
all right and then
it just comes out and then you flip it
flip it and you get your design
press real hard
so we have our corzetti here so we're
going to start with a little olive oil
olive oil
i like to coat that and you want to try
it sort of on on a lowest sheet because
you never want to put garlic in a super
hot pan
this has been heating up a little so
this is going to be real quick i love
that tip don't let the pan get too hot
like ever to brown the garlic i hate it
i always like it so you just want to
smell it you want to smell that aroma
and then we're going to take a little
water
from your pasta water
and we're going to put it in the pan and
this is what's going to start your sauce
then we're going to take some butter
you see how the butter is slowly kind of
emulsifying into here let's just put it
all in
and what you're looking for here is to
really get it
to this nice sauce consistency a little
viscosity
so you're going to take this pasta out
and you always want to have your pasta
be able to cook a little bit in your
sauce we call that the marriage ceremony
al dente just became something a lot
more romantic yeah i think that i think
that the marriage ceremony is the key to
pasta making then we're going to take
some parsley very underrated herb it's
it's a flavor it's good i think a lot of
times people just throw it in
a garnish or it's all over a plate and
it doesn't need to be um it already has
that beautiful in this it's color it's
flavor it's it's vibrancy
um so you're just going to add that in
you always want to do that at the very
very very end so it doesn't wilt so it
doesn't turn color so it stays fresh um
all right so we're going to plate now
and we're just going to take this this
is kind of a not oh wow you went for it
i'm doing mine a little a little
different oh god what have i done well
i'm just pleating with a spoon
because
i teach my cooks not to do the dump and
if i went on tv and did the dump i'd get
in a lot of trouble okay i am the dumb
person for sure you did it you went for
it i went for it
and then very important this is
parmigiano-reggiano
parmigiano
and then finally pine nuts
and then your marjoram which is really
going to take it to the next level
okay
and then i always like to do just a
little drizzle of olive oil to finish
oh dear
and we're good
perfect and you it there you go look at
that very artistic
oh missy i want to marry you okay
and maddie shall we taste yeah let's do
a little taste oh my goodness okay a
little taste
oh my gosh i
wow
oh my god
oh my
god
oh my god this pasta makes me want to
marry both of you okay great
let's do it
by the way
throttles are trending so that's perfect
yes um oh maddie i wish you the very
best of luck and thank you for sharing
the charity that you're doing with it
um and in honor of that we're going to
put that on our website and put you up
there so if anybody let me contribute to
maddie's organization please go to the
drewberrymore show.com and
missy robbins i have waited for this
moment i have manifested it i love you
so much
missy cookbook
pasta
most beautiful cookbook i've ever seen
it is out now and available everywhere
books are sold cookbook club holy cow
they drop the mic maddie good luck we'll
be cheering you on
[Music]
you